[Music]
pick is random for some Python and so
that's going to be broken down into four
basic sections first a little bit of
basic background about the model and how
its implemented a couple of explanatory
examples I'm going to talk a little bit
about random forests versus neural Nets
because neural nets are a very popular
topic and model choice so a bit of
exploration as to why you might choose
one or the other and then end off with
an example sort of toy AI using random
forests so it's an ensemble machine
learning model which basically means
that it's an aggregation of a bunch of
simpler models in this case decision
trees so the individual trees are formed
by branching on features in a data set
and the random forest is an aggregation
of these decision tree models so the
decision trees as mentioned branch on
each of the features in order to create
a partition of the data so for each pin
in that partition ie
a leaf in the tree you can assign a
output value which will be corresponding
to each of the inputs that fall into
that bin so two major types of trees
first classification trees your output
is categorical and so each branch of the
tree formed by a particular set of
feature values leads to a different
particular output value so as an example
if you're building a decision tree to
show the prisoner's dilemma game your
two features are whether or not the two
prisoners cooperate and so based on
those four different possible outcomes
in the space the tree has four different
leaves and a different set of payoffs
for each of those different
configurations regression tree you are
again trying to partition the output
space but in this case the output is
continuous
and so the way that you assign the
continuous value at these leaves is to
take the mean of the values assigned to
a particular bin so just for a very
simple example absolute value of x from
negative 10 to 10 you only have 3
features in this case which will give
you 4 branches which partitions the
output and for possible ranges and so
you'd have a different output value for
each of those ranges it's fairly clear
to see that the finer you make the
partition
I even more features you have and the
deeper the tree the closer you can get
to approximating an actual continuous
output um so it's clear that the order
of the branches in the tree matters it's
less transparent how the path each leaf
is constructed and so in practice this
a-kor happens according to an approach
called entropy minimization in which you
for each feature minimize the entropy or
maximize the information gain and choose
the feature to branch on which maximizes
the an information game I've left out
the formula because it's not
particularly intuitive if you're not
familiar with information science but
there is some pretty simple intuition to
understand how that branching process
occurs so the problem is basically given
a set of features how you partition the
output space as finely as possible as
quickly as possible and for useful
analogy I would point you to the game
guess who so in the game guess who for
those of you that don't know players try
to identify the opposing players
character from a preset list of
characters and to do that individuals
take turns asking yes or no questions to
expose features about the character so
low information gain the way that people
typically play this game is to ask
questions like whether character or
wears glasses or has like hair
and these represent low information game
features so generally I ask you know
does a character wear glasses the answer
is no I've eliminated maybe three
possibilities and I haven't gotten very
far a higher information gain feature
will partition the data as evenly as
possible regardless of the answer so in
the case of a yes-or-no question the
best you can do is to partition the data
in half with each question so a high
information information gain question
would be something to the effect of is
your character Bob or Ted or Jenner and
list half the characters and then you
have yes or no question that guarantees
to eliminate half of all your
possibilities so in this way you've
eliminated half the possibilities and in
general
you can identify the target character in
log n guesses so that's decision trees
and now we move into making the forest
from these decision trees so overfitting
is a well-known pitfall for these
decision trees this should be fairly
clear to see from the guest to example
building a feature that's like is your
character in this half of all characters
is very overfitting and if the data
changes at all it's likely to
underperform a more general feature like
the kind of questions that you would
generally ask like you know what hair
and so the way that we overcome this
pitfall is by building an ensemble model
from these decision trees and we do this
with a procedure called bagging so just
to make it explicit what an ensemble
model is is a model that is made by
aggregating other models so in our case
averaging a bunch of decision trees is
going to result in predictions they're
still unbiased like the individual trees
but because it's an aggregation of a
bunch of other models the variance of
our estimator will go down so the
bagging procedure is for some number of
trees key and
predetermined depth we select a subset
of the data usually 2/3 you can tune
that parameter based on the requirements
of your problem you train a decision
tree using a subset of the features on
that subset of the data again the square
root of the number of features is the
convention but you can tune that based
on your particular problem so if you
think that your features have a complex
interaction then you might want to have
a deeper tree because you would want the
decision trees to capture the
interaction of those features but if you
think your features are you know largely
independent than having very deep
decision trees doesn't make a lot of
sense so you train the individual trees
like that and then they can be
aggregated so in the case of a
classification problem we can use the
mode of the individual trees to form our
aggregate prediction in the case of a
regression problem we can use the mean
of the trees and so that way you know we
can use the the individual models that
we've trained to get either a
categorical or regression output and
that process happens completely
independently from how the trees are
trained so this helps us avoid
overfitting the individual trees it's
hard to overfit them if you're only
using a subset of the available
information and by building the random
forests we can build sort of a stronger
aggregation model from the from these
weaker models and that the individual to
treat decision trees while unbiased are
weakly predictive and so this
disaggregation reduces the variance of
the subsets of trees so strong suits of
random forests the reason that they're
sort of generally very effective tool is
that they're robust
lots of different kinds of data so
nonlinear non monotonic functions if
your data is on unscaled data with
missing values poorly chosen features so
what this all sort of combines too is if
you don't have a lot of preconceived
notions about your data set then random
forests tend to be a very good sort of
first pass model to try so a couple of
examples nonlinear functions so we'll
start with the functions at x times the
sine of X plus some random value it's a
pretty simple function but a lot of
models will have trouble sort of
capturing that nonlinear non monotonic
behavior certainly something like simple
regression as like a easy out-of-the-box
thing to try will fail miserably here
unless you have some very clever feature
extraction so simple code to generate
the example a generate data function
which will map X value to the output
that we just discussed so X Y we
generate the data and then I'm taking a
random forest regressor from
scikit-learn there's absolutely zero
parameter tuning here it's just straight
out of the box application of the
regressor model and the output we get is
this so that yellow line being traced
through the data is the model prediction
and the blue dots are actual data points
so without any kind of tuning we're
capturing this sort of complex shape of
the function fairly easily and while
there is a bit of noise in the function
it still sort of captures the basic
behavior of the function yeah
so the next example I wanted to look at
is unscaled features so in this example
we'll just take points across the four
quadrants of the Cartesian plane
so like northeast northwest Stephanie's
from Southwest but the one tricky piece
here is that we're going to use weird
ranges so the X values will cover just
negative point one to one all the Y
values will go from negative five
thousand five thousand and so our our
two axes are a pretty different scale
here so again very simple example
function to classify the quadrant of a
given point and then x and y are just
randomly simulated pairs and then we
take a random force classifier and fit
the coordinates to the quadrant again
there's absolutely no parameter tuning
here this is just naive out-of-the-box
and this is the output that you get from
that basically exactly what you would
hope for all of the points are
classified correctly despite the very
awkward ranges and for those of you that
were thinking in the last example that
our regression model was overfitting to
a lot of noise and that a model like you
know neighbors or Sdn or sorry SVM would
fit this more smoothly that might be
true but in an example like this models
like that that are sort of sensitive to
the scale of features are going to fail
pretty miserably so for example K
nearest neighbors out of the box will
give you this so will capture the north
and south pieces but completely miss the
more fine x axis and if you do this with
the support vector machines you'll again
get these exact same results
so models like that would require sort
of more tuning or feature extraction so
forest versus neural Nets neural nets
are very popular and they work very well
why not just use them for everything
parameter tuning tends to be a lot
simpler to fold so even if you do need
to do parameter tuning for examples that
are more complicated than the sort of
toy examples that I've just run through
there are sort of clear conventions
around choosing parameters and there's
pretty clear intuition around like how
you would choose things so you know
deciding the depth of a tree depends on
the complexity of feature interaction or
like choosing the number of trees
depends on like a trade-off of training
time versus performance there's very
sort of clear easy intuition for how you
choose these parameters whereas in the
case of a neural network saying I want
my network to have four layers with this
particular network topology and X like
connectivity and weights the intuition
behind how you choose those things is
not particularly obvious there's a more
robust body of academic literature
around force just for the reason that
they've sort of been around longer which
makes the internal workings easier to
understand which again goes to this
issue of being able to make sort of
reasonable judgments about tuning models
generally simpler to implement the
examples that I just did with the random
forests obviously those are you know
uniquely simple cases but it's just
model dot fit model dot predicts there's
not a whole lot else to it where is even
with sort of simple wrappers like Karros
there's still a fair amount of
configuration around creating the
individual layers and making decisions
about the the topology of the layers uh
scaling so
random forests are inherently
parallelizable and extremely well
supported for distributed deployment so
through ML Lib which is included in
SPARC you can do a distributed random
forest very easily the actual syntax
winds up being basically the same as
through scikit-learn and you can do that
for arbitrarily large datasets because
the data is partitioned over a cluster
and so given that each decision tree is
pulling a subset of the data your data
will be co-located with the tree it's
trained on and so you're just
aggregating the trees from the cluster
doing that kind of distributed
deployment of a neural net is much less
straightforward so the last thing that I
want to do is a simple AI example with
random forests and so the problem that
we're going to run through is basically
building a simple array search so given
an array of sorted numbers we'd like to
find a target value as quickly as
possible the standard example here or
the standard approach would be binary
search but in our case we're going to
say that the random values are
exponentially distributed and so our
challenge is to use this information to
build a search algorithm that faster
than binary search so the approach we're
going to take is to create a bunch of of
sample searches so random search just
randomly picking values linear search
going in whatever direction one by one
until we find our value binary search
the sort of prescribed algorithm and at
each step we're going to create an
observation the observation will be our
current location a floor on the range
that we know a ceiling on the range that
we know and a ratio of the value at our
current index over the target value that
we're looking for which presumably
encodes some information about how far
away
a our target value is according to the
underlying distribution of the values so
I am NOT going to go through all the
code to actually generate this you can
go to that repo and find everything if
you want to actually look through the
internals this is this will basically
captures the gist of it so you have a
search simulation class which will take
a training size and an array size in
this case the array size will just be
100 and it will generate a set of states
instead of prescribed deltas so then we
can build a random forest classifier
that fits the states to prescribe Delta
and then build a search class that
updates its locations based on its
prediction of the appropriate Delta at
its current location and given its
current state so the results of this of
our four searches random search at the
far left and linear than binary and then
a I search slightly outperforming that
and then just to dive into a bit a I
search versus binary there you know so
binary search is here in the blue on the
left and a I search is the red one so
you can see at the extreme end there are
a couple of cases in which a I search
under performs binary and so you in a
sort of production application would
probably want to do some deeper dive on
like these tail examples to figure out
sort of why it's getting confused in
that case but for the most part at
almost every quantile the AI search is
fairly substantially outperforming
binary
and yeah that's that's what I got yeah
as I mentioned I think there oh yeah
sorry the question is why you would
choose random forests over other methods
and I think the reason that I like
random forests is that they are very
robust to a lot of different types of
data so certainly if you have sort of
preconceived notions about your data set
that suggests a specific model by all
means do that but random forests will
tend to give you at least a reasonable
answer regardless of you know your data
unless you're making some pretty wild
choices so it's a very good
out-of-the-box I'm trying to just build
something reasonable as quickly as
possible kind of approach
it's not actually super connected to the
work that I do at Bloomberg I actually
do like data pipeline kind of stuff so
it's a lot more like distributed systems
barkay to ingestion kind of stuff sorry
I realize it's not a very helpful answer
sorry could you speak up a little bit a
bit about feature ok yeah yeah so I mean
I guess in general like you in the case
of random forests if you have like a lot
of irrelevant features if you're
training a lot of decision trees based
on those features you could wind up with
an erroneous model so I guess one way to
sort of do feature extraction is if
you're training on sort of shallower
trees then and shallower trees with a
larger subset of the features so each
decision tree has the sort of full pool
to pull from then your individual
decision trees will tend to pick up on
the features that actually matter
because they have the full sort of
option sorry the full set of features to
choose from while you're doing the the
entropy minimization procedure so that
is sort of a way in which you can sort
of quickly get a sense of the features
that matter and if you do think you have
sort of features that need to be pruned
that would be sort of a way to identify
that set I don't know if I'm answering
the question right
yeah I mean I don't sir so that yeah so
the question is basically how does
current implementations of random
forests deal with categorical features I
I wouldn't comment necessarily on like
specific implementations but as a model
random forests are pretty well set up to
deal with categorical data because like
the underlying model or trees so if I
have categorical features then like my
branching is on each possible output
value of an underlying feature and so if
I have you know just all categorical
data to make an extreme case then like
there's really no need for like any kind
of continuous approximation it's all
just binning according to those those
categories
I would say in general it kind of
depends on the implementation or library
that you're using but if you do you have
categorical data as a guarantee against
having any issues there you can do one
hot encoding so basically like for each
categorical value you extract that into
features that say instead of so a
categorical feature that can have like
values a B and C I extract new features
that say a equals 1 B equals 1 C equals
1 and then I have numerical values and
so I don't have to you know worry about
that issue so individual trees I I can
build the tree without if I have
individual values that have like missing
columns the sub trees can be trained on
a sub set of features that don't include
that particular column so the question
is a compare random forests to other
techniques in terms of training speed
there's obviously a pretty wide universe
of other techniques so that's like a
pretty difficult question to answer
succinctly yes so in general I think
again depends on the architecture of the
neural net but like in very extreme
cases you can get I think sort of faster
training performance with a random force
particularly if you do like some kind of
parallel or distributed approach because
the individual trees are pretty amenable
to being done in parallel them and
aggregated whereas you know in the case
of a neural network there's a lot of
reaction that has to happen so it's not
necessarily easy to train the net with
you know all of your data being in
different places on a single machine the
amount of training time you know could
very much be the question of the
architecture of the net
[Applause]
[Music]